Sonneberg reden reden wir über eine
demokratische Wahl die gestern
stattgefunden hat ich muss auch zugeben
dass ich mich sehr darüber gefreut habe
dass die Wahl Beteiligung deutlich
zugenommen hat sicherlich gefällt mir
ein Ergebnis weniger wenn ein Mensch
gewählt wird da ein Parteibuch hat einer
Partei die von unserem Landesamt für
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch seit zweieinhalb
Jahren eingeordnet wird trotzdem ist es
eine Wahl die demokratisch legitimiert
ist und eine Wahl bei der eine Mehrheit
entschieden hat sie haben diesem
Kandidaten an Sessel man das Vertrauen
ausgesprochen und Herr Sesselmann wird
jetzt diesen Landkreis als Verwaltung
führen wir reden über eine Verwaltungs
ein verwaltungsmandat es ist ein
wahlmandat für die öffentliche
Verwaltung eingebettet in die
Mehrheitsverhältnisse des Kreistages
insoweit kann auch Herr Sesselmann nicht
frei agieren wie er möchte sondern es
eingebettet in recht und Gesetz er ist
gebunden an alle Vorgaben die für uns
für jeden Landkreis Gültigkeit haben und
seinen Stellvertreter und die
Beigeordneten haben dass Mandat dann vom
Kreistag und im Kreistag hat die AFD
keine Mehrheit insoweit bitte ich darum
auch etwas
entspannter in einer Situation die Dinge
zu durchdringen die tatsächlich ein
Tabubruch darstellen das hat man ja
gestern Auf und Ab in ganz Deutschland
bemerkt wenn Thüringen auf einmal Platz
1 oder Platz zwei in den
Hauptnachrichtensendungen hat und es in
der Regel dann mit einer Botschaft
verbunden ist die nicht schön ist dann
hat man das Gefühl dass Thüringen in
einer völlig anderen Art wahrgenommen
wird mehr wäre es auch recht gewesen
wenn wir mit der Firma Griesson den
Hauptnachrichten gehabt hätten immerhin
140 Millionen in kahler in die größte
Keksfabrik die Deutschland überhaupt hat
die in Europa produziert die
Prinzenrolle kennt jeder aber dass sie
aus Thüringen kommt weiß wieder niemand
und deswegen das da 340 Millionen von
dem Unternehmen in 30 Jahren verbaut
worden sind Hightech pur funktioniert
und das ist auch in Sonneberg Sonneberg
ist unser industriestärkster Landkreis
und dieser industriestärkste Landkreis
exportiert in alle europäischen Länder
das heißt der Euro Euro Raum ist für
Sonneberg und die Betriebe und Sonneberg
von existenzieller Bedeutung dass dann
ein Kandidat gewinnt der den Austritt
aus dem Euro möchte das macht deutlich
dass da Rinn in dieser Wahlentscheidung
der Sonneberger etwas anderes
eingebettet ist und für mich ist es so
ich lasse das auf mich wirken und stelle
fest dass der Zustand der deutschen
Einheit psychologisch einige Macken
erlitten hat weil Menschen das Gefühl
haben dass über sie geredet wird aber
das was sie einbringen nicht
wahrgenommen wird und an dieser Stelle
will ich nichts entschuldigen will
nichts relativieren ich habe auch keine
Lust jetzt in diese Empörung mit
einzusteigen und deutlich zu machen als
wenn Sonneberg jetzt untergehen würde
der Landkreis Sonneberg untergehen würde
aber zur Betrachtung gehört eben auch
dass der entfremdungsprozess auch der
parlamentarische entfremdungsprozess in
einer regionalen kommunal und
demokratischen Verfasstheit ein längerer
ist und dass die CDU in Sonneberg kein
Landrat mehr stellt dass die CDU die
langjährige CDU Landrätin Frau Zitzmann
mittlerweile nicht mal mehr Mitglied der
CDU ist das in der Stadt Sonneberg ein
Kandidat der ursprünglich mal von der
CDU aufgestellt worden ist am Ende in
einer Konkurrenzsituation durch ein
CDU-Kandidaten dann wiederum angegriffen
worden ist angegriffen im Sinne eines
Wahlkampfes gegen den eigenen Kandidaten
das darüber die kommunale Familie der
CDU auch zerbrochen ist das ist etwas
was mir auch Sorgen bereitet dass die
Frage der regionalen Verankerung die
regionale Rückbindung und auch die
Kompetenz sich in die
Verwaltungsabläufe eines Landkreises
oder einer Stadt so einzubringen dass
man für seine Region kämpft und deswegen
sage ich aus meiner Perspektive es ist
auch ein Hinweis darauf was ich am 3
oktober in meiner Rede zum der deutschen
Einheit versucht habe kritisch zu
formulieren wenn man nicht versteht dass
die Rentenpunkte Ost-West alleine nicht
das Thema repariert was an Bitternis
vorhanden ist geschiedene Eheleute
mithelfen der Ehefrauen all diese Renten
Problemfälle die individuell
wahrgenommen werden und als Verletzung
wahrgenommen werden das wiegt nicht auf
dass wir tatsächlich seit einer Woche
gleiche Rentenpunkte Ost-West haben ich
freue mich darüber dass es so ist aber
ich grämme mich darüber dass die
Probleme die immer noch nicht repariert
sind nach 30 Jahren nicht mal erkannt
werden und dass man unter diesem Aspekt
Sonneberg wiederum nur als ostdeutsches
Phänomen wahrnimmt das finde ich ein
Problem und ich werbe dafür mein
Bundesland Thüringen als Ganzes mit
seiner Stärke wahrzunehmen auch mit den
Herausforderungen aber ich war aber auch
dafür dass alle Demokraten in
Deutschland sich klar werden müssen dass
die deutsche Einheit nur gelingen kann
haben wir auch den Menschen das Gefühl
geben dass sie mit ihren Sorgen nicht
nur gesehen werden sondern auch an den
sorgen gearbeitet wird insoweit ist der
Sonntag für mich ein nachhaltiger
Denkanstoß über vieles der eingespielten
Rituale neu nachzudenken und ich werbe
dafür dass wir den Geist der deutschen
Einheit wieder mehr in den Mittelpunkt
bekommen wirtschaftlich sind wir stark
geworden durch deutsche Solidarität
innerdeutsche Solidarität
psychologisch können wir nur stark
werden wenn die Menschen in den neuen
Ländern das Gefühl haben dass nicht über
sie geredet wird sondern sie selber Teil
des eigenen Veränderungsprozesses werden
ich habe versucht darauf hinzuweisen
dass Sonneberg ein Vorlauf hat und auch
der Kandidat Körper der ja anderthalb
Jahre oder über anderthalb Jahre das Amt
geführt hat und zwar in schwierigen
Zeiten und alleine dass ich vor 14 Tagen
erwähnt habe er hat es vor 14 er hat es
über eine lange Zeit gut gemacht hat ja
dazu geführt dass die AFD mir
unterstellt hat ich würde damit meine
Neutralitätspflicht verletzen und die
Ankündigung Werder Wehen alles im Moment
in den in die Ecke stellen will ich
dafür noch meine persönliche Erfahrung
sagen seit dem Termin vor 14 Tagen als
ich das für einen Körper gesagt habe
dass er ordentlich die Arbeit des
amtierenden Landrats gemacht hat habe
ich einen Shitstorm auf Twitter erlebt
ich habe mittlerweile
Twitter Accounts geblockt
alles nur noch Hass ist purer Hass und
jetzt erlebe ich seit gestern Abend die
umgekehrte Reihenfolge einmal von denen
die sich riesig freuen die jetzt auch
darüber philosophieren dass man jetzt
schwarze Listen anlegen müsste und wie
man Rache nehmen müsste und was nicht
alles und ich erlebe viele auch aus dem
eher liberalen oder linken Bereich die
der Meinung sind es ist alles mist das
ist alles falsch gelaufen diese Form
über die Situation zu urteilen ohne sich
in die Situation hinein zu bewegen die
macht mir Sorgen deswegen alleine
einfach nur zu sagen nach der Wahl bis
zur Stichwahl jetzt sollten alle den
einen Kandidaten also unterstützen das
alleine wird uns nicht helfen wenn wir
vor der ersten Wahl uns nicht
verständigen was heißt für uns
demokratische Wahl und wie gehen wir als
Demokraten miteinander um nicht wie
machen wir die Tonart des Populismus
noch hochwege also wenn man die AFD
nachahmt oder nachäfft wird es immer nur
auf die AFD selber einzahlen wir
brauchen Menschen die mit den Beinen auf
der Erde stehen und für Demokratie
entstehen und auch sagen wir sind
unterschiedlicher Meinung wir haben
nicht ein gemeinsames Wahlprogramm wir
sind unterschiedliche Parteien aber es
gibt eine Abgrenzung die Abgrenzung zu
einem
nachgewiesenermaßen Parteiapparat der
nachgewiesenermaßen rechtsextrem ist
bundespolitischen Themen gepunktet ne
ich habe da nicht auch irgendwas auf was
dass die Leute generell einfach
unzufrieden ist es ist ja vielleicht
doch nicht eher so eine regionale
Entscheidung sondern eher etwas über die
Bundesrepublik aus es sagt etwas darüber
aus dass tatsächlich und deswegen habe
ich von einem Denkzettel gestern Abend
auch gesprochen wenn er Sesselmann sagt
er will aus dem Euro austreten das geht
ein Landrat überhaupt nichts an da kann
der Landrat als Mensch eine Meinung zu
haben aber wer in Sonneberg aus dem Euro
austreten will und nicht versteht dass
seine Betriebe alle den Euro-Raum
bedienen dass sie ein starker Partner im
Euroraum sind und das Sonneberg die
Mischung ist zwischen Osten und West
dass der Tag der Franken den die Bayern
in Sonneberg durchgeführt haben ein
unglaublich erfolgreiches Wochenende war
bei denen sehr sehr viele Menschen aus
Westdeutschland da waren und man gar
nicht gespürt hat dass sie aus
Westdeutschland waren sondern auf einmal
waren ist Franken und das dann eine
Tonart kommt die im Kern sagt die da
oben sind alle mist das führt zu einer
gefährlichen Schieflage weil das hat mit
den realen Problemen die Sonneberg hat
nichts mehr zu tun
Manuel Richter jetzt wieder die Stimme
des nüchternen Politikwissenschaftler zu
der Stimme des Politikers wir haben sie
das wahrgenommen was Polo Ramelow eben
gesagt hat auf die als Reaktion auf die
erste Wahl eines
afd-politikers als Landrat
naja seine Pflicht ist es ja
gewissermaßen als Ministerpräsident das
Land Thüringen zu verteidigen und die
Thüringer Bürgerinnen und Bürger und das
hat er ja getan und ich glaube er hat
richtigerweise hingewiesen auf die
bundespolitische Ebene und auf diesen
Geist der Verunglimpfung und der
Polarisierung der der Politik nicht gut
tut also insofern hat er schon die
richtige Wahrnehmung an dieser Stelle
wir müssen uns nur daran erinnern er ist
ja in gewisser Weise ein schwacher
Ministerpräsident weil er abhängig ist
vom Zuspruch der CDU weil er im Landtag
eben keine richtige Mehrheit hat und
weil eben die Werte die Wähler
Stimmenanteile der AFD in den Prognosen
nach oben schnellen das heißt also die
nächste Landtagswahl die in 14 Monaten
stattfinden wird die Thüringen mit der
muss auf die muss er mit Sorge blicken
weil es verm ruhig sein wird dass er
nicht länger Ministerpräsident ist wenn
die Stimmung sich so in der Wahl
abbildet wie sie jetzt in den Prognosen
vorhanden ist alles hängt mit allen
zusammen also die Bundesebene und die
lokale Ebene Sprache aber auch von einem
parlamentarischen
entfremdungsprozess das lässt natürlich
jeden Demokraten aufhorchen
wie hoch ist der in der thüringischen
Stimme die dann auch nächstes Jahr
Landtagswahl Stimme sein wird
naja wir erinnern uns vielleicht an die
Ereignisse im Februar März 2020 als
Thomas Kemmerich der fdp-kandidat in
einer merkwürdigen Art parlamentarischen
Abstimmung Marathons zum
Ministerpräsidenten für ein paar Tage
gewählt worden ist wo es ja
riesige
Proteste gab und wo es wirklich ein
Beben durch die ganze Republik ging was
ist da geschehen und der afd-kandidat
der ja nur als zellkandidat eingebracht
worden war der ist ja dann im letzten
Wahlgang zurückgezogen worden also wo
die AFD ähm ein gewisses Misstrauen
gegen das Parlament in dem sich selber
sitzt
bekundet hat und die Missbilligung
parlamentarische
abstimmungsabläufe also insofern war das
schon damals ein denkwürdiger
Vorgang und das Thüringer Parlament
hat eben eine starke afd-fraktion es hat
eine CDU-Fraktion die sich da immer
schwankend auch gegenüber der
afd-positioniert hat was ja der
CDU-Vorsitzende Bundesvorsitzende auch
immer wieder angemahnt hat also insofern
ist da einiges in Bewegung einige
Aufruhr im Parlament angesiedelt was in
anderen Landesparlamenten so dramatisch
nicht der Fall ist also insofern ist das
schon in Thüringen eine besondere
Situation aber viel über die Chancen
auch der AFD gesprochen sprich mir auch
über die Grenzen es sind ja
Landtagswahlen dieses Jahr in Bayern das
liegt direkt quasi südlich von Sonneberg
ist Coburg schon in Bayern Hessen der
nächstes Jahr Brandenburg Sachsen und
Thüringen molligen die Grenzen des AFD
Wahlergebnis
wir wissen ja dass in den westlichen
Bundesländern die AFD nicht so große
Erfolge hat wie in den östlichen ja also
da gibt es eine deutliche Diskrepanz
insofern würde ich prognostizieren und
das zeigen ja auch die Wahlprognosen
dass die AFD Stimmenanteile in jetzt den
bevorstehenden Wahlen Hessen und Bayern
leicht ansteigen werden wobei in Bayern
noch nicht so ganz sicher bin aber nicht
so dramatisch wie es jetzt die Werte der
letzten Umfragen gezeigt haben wo eben
die AFD massiv an Stimmen und Zuspruch
gewonnen hat also ich bin ehrlich gesagt
fast noch gespannte auf die Bayern war
als auf die Hessenwahl in Bezug auf die
AFD Stimmenanteile weil in Bayern die
AFD ja auch eine ganz schwierige
Position hat sie hat sich im Parlament
gewissermaßen selbst zerlegt viele
Abgeordnete sind da ausgetreten dann hat
sie den starken Gegner gewissermaßen der
Freien Wähler die ja auch zum Teil zu
einer rechtsnationalistische Rhetorik an
den Tag gelegt haben eiwan als Auftritt
neulich also insofern gibt es da interne
Verwerfungen im bayerischen Parlament im
Bayerischen Landtag und in Hessen muss
man eben sehen wie insbesondere die
anderen Parteien abschneiden also ob die
CDU grüne Regierung da bestätigt wird
auch das ist ja noch nicht so ganz
sicher und insofern sind das beides
schon noch spannende Ereignisse in
Hinblick auch auf die Entwicklung der
AFD Stimmenanteile die ja gerade im in
einem hoch sich befinden immer Manuel
Richter mit Einsichten und Aussichten
auch zur Lage der AFD war dass ich danke
Ihnen sehr dafür wünsche Ihnen einen
guten und angenehmen Tag tschüss